[Musique]
le quartier de la clef Saint-Pierre
réaménagé et végétalisé à l'horizon des
JO de Paris 2024 vendredi 3 février
Jean-Michel fourgouse mère d'Élancourt a
signé un contrat d'aménagement régional
c'est de donner un grand souffle aussi à
ce quartier
dans la rénovation dans la modernisation
de la meilleure
adaptation aux questions que nous pose
nos administrés donc c'est un grand
projet leur bien entendu tout cela c'est
extrêmement poussé aussi avec l'arrivée
des JO parmi les transformations prévues
pour 2023 les réaménagements paysagers
du premier rond-point avenue Maurice
Dassault sur le thème des jeux ou encore
celui de la place de Berlin et le
fleurissement du second rond-point le
couteau tal est estimé à 4 millions
d'euros hors-taxe dont un million
financé par la Région si la région ne
venait pas accompagner toutes les
communes de d'Île-de-France et bien
beaucoup seraient amené à ne plus
investir à moins investir une commune
qui n'investit plus une commune qui
n'est plus attractive et puis je
rappelle également que nous sommes dans
un pays où 70% d'investissement public
c'est les collectivités locales le jour
où les collectivités locales
n'investissent plus c'est l'économie qui
est en panne la Croix-Rouge se modernise
et regroupe ses activités samedi 4
février avait lieu l'inauguration des
nouveaux locaux de l'association à
Guyancourt en présence du président
national le but regrouper toutes les
activités sur un même site après les
journées de grève des 19 et 31 janvier
la mobilisation continue contre le
projet de réforme des retraites vendredi
3 février avait lieu une manifestation
au flambeau à Mantes-la-Jolie Poissy
Versailles et Rambouillet organisé par
la CGT et l’inter syndicale
départementale des Yvelines les
syndicats appellent à une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation le mardi 7
février
55% c'est le taux de participation aux
élections municipales à Buchelay ce
dimanche Stéphane Tremblay qui assurait
l'intérim depuis décembre dernier après
la démission de Paul Martinez a été élue
la liste du candidat sans étiquette à
récolter plus de 60% des voix ils
devancent largement ses adversaires fade
gazouani et Saphia el manani et on
termine avec notre image du jour
l'Europe était à l'honneur ce matin au
lycée Jean d'Albert de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye l'euro député
Marie-Pierre vedren est venu à la
rencontre des lycéens au programme de la
matinée des discussions sur différents
thèmes européens
[Musique]